foreign
other question here this one is from
Renee this is Renee from Ocala Florida I
have always wanted to keep a journal I
don't have the greatest memories but I
love to look back on moments
um how do you feel about journaling
digital versus physical especially in
this day and age with everything being
in digital like I work in H5 job where I
sit at a computer all day and know if
this was harming my eyes or if a
physical approach would be more of a
better suit
well during our more about less segment
today I've got this essay from Kapil
Gupta and it totally changed my mind
about how we think about memories now
for the longest time of course I thought
the same way everyone thought about
memories I wouldn't let go of my things
because oh I don't want to let go of my
memories right and so I would hold on to
those things not realizing that the
memories aren't in the things the
memories are in me in fact you saw that
in our last Netflix film less is now I
talk about our memories not being in the
things the memories being inside us and
it is possible to let go of a thing and
still retain the memory Kapil takes it
even a step further which we'll see
later today on the private podcast here
what Kapil shows you is that well you
don't really need those memories
necessarily A person who enjoys the now
needn't cling to Memories for happiness
now as soon as I say that someone would
say oh but my memories I love my
memories okay I'm not telling you to get
rid of memories I'm simply saying that
memories are often a way for us to cling
to the way things were it's the disease
of nostalgia and that is often when we
cling to those memories we cling to the
things so journaling for me if it's just
a way to cling to Memories
I don't find it to be particularly
useful for me however
where I do find journaling to be
interesting and useful is if it helps me
discover how I think about something it
helps me better understand a situation
about my life or a greater truth about
the world or a situational truth then I
don't call it journaling I just write I
write every morning and I don't care
about the vehicle
often I teach a writing class at
howtomwritebetter.org and often students
will ask something and Professor Sean
can attest to this like what pin do you
use yeah what Journal do you use as
though if you handed me Stephen King's
pencil I'm going to write the book
Carrie no of course I'm not it is just a
tool and he didn't need that particular
pencil I saw an ad the other day in the
Paris review which is my favorite
quarterly publication
and it was an ad for a really expensive
pin a Mont Blanc pin right
and I'm sure they're really nice I bet
you they write really well but the ad
was pretending that if I have the Mont
block pin then I am the type of person
who can pin something that is
Everlasting that is true that is
profound and thus without it yeah then I
cannot be the writer that I want to be I
can't be the best version of myself so
yes I write every day I was writing
early this morning and it helps me
figure out what I think about the world
it helps me better understand the world
but I don't do it to cling to my
memories yeah I bought a pair of Mont
block sunglasses like a decade ago you
remember that yes when we're in Chicago
they fell apart like a year and a half
later anyway they look nice they did
look really nice yeah just like a pin
though right right and now what if you
said without those sunglasses I can no
longer go out into the sun right I can't
see the world as good yeah as well as if
I didn't have the Mont block sunglasses
no it is it is crazy how
specifically with something like Mont
Blanc like it really is just built on a
name which is built from marketing and
advertising and there are there are some
good pens I mean I'm not a pen
Enthusiast but I hear that they do a
good job but it really comes down to
that perceived value that they're making
you think it's worth
um but to your point it's like you could
write as good of a paragraph with this
pen I have in my hand here or a mountain
block pattern yes and I would argue that
the Mont Blanc well it may be a
technically a better writing utensil
yeah if you become dependent on it now
all of a sudden it's cluttered not yeah
because this pin that I have right here
this is a pilot G2 uh the it's a size 10
that's the the the thickness of the ink
these are the kind we use here in the
studio this is the kind I typically use
it's a great pen yeah it serves me
better than the Mont Blanc why yeah not
because of the pen because I never worry
about it if this thing gets lost today I
just pick up another pilot G2 and it's
not a problem and if you have to have a
Montblanc pen to write a good paragraph
like how limiting is that it's so
limiting yeah Professor Sean um I I will
see that Mont Blanc fountain pens are
beautiful fountain pens but it's funny
because you just held up the pilot G2
and pilot makes a beautiful fountain pen
that is
I don't know one-fifth one-sixth
one-tenth the price of a month long
Fountain then yeah I've owned one for
like a decade and it's it's my
journaling pen when I rarely journal and
it's great yeah yeah what about you
what's your writing utensil TK I don't
even pay attention to those details he
just Pricks his finger and rice some
blood but that doesn't mean I'm so
sophisticated that I don't pay attention
it means I'm so unsophisticated that I
don't really know the difference uh well
when it comes to stuff it means that you
don't put up barriers in front of
yourself to write like could you imagine
getting up and being like Oh it's time
to write oh no where's my Mont Blanc pen
I don't have it yeah and now like I
can't write because I don't have a
specific pen I'm like Eminem and Eight
Mile I'd just be like writing on the
back of napkins yes whatever pan is
Handy
there was a Michelle Branch album I
think it was called Hotel paper and she
had written all the lyrics so while she
was touring on Hotel paper right just
like because when you go to stay at a
hotel a lot of times they have this
little cheap pad of paper there and a
cheap little big yeah but she created an
entire body of work I love it with the
things that are perceived to be thrown
away because ultimately it's all throw
away anyway all of the memories on a
long enough timeline they're all a
throwaway all of the accessories we have
to capture those memories whether it's
the the nicest binder or the nicest
notebook or the nicest pin it's all
throw away at the end of the day did you
enjoy this Standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free